c'est dans cette maison d'une rue calme
de châtillon en bazois qu'un couple a
été arrêté mercredi dernier
suspecté avec six autres personnes
d'abus sexuels et de violences sur
quatre garçons de 4 à 9 ans de deux
fratries différentes
des accusations qui provoque la
stupéfaction dans le voisinage même si
la famille était défavorablement connue
en fin d'année un projet qui a pris man
n'ont pas l'audace famille dans son
placard n'a pas donné à manger tue et 3g
l'enfant est condamné pour ça mais tu
puisque s'agissait pas à pas
au total huit personnes ont été
interpellées
les deux couples de parents ainsi qu'un
troisième coupe les deux hommes de leur
entourage
une affaire mise au jour après le
placement des enfants sur signalement
des services éducatifs plus de dix mois
d'enquêté ont ensuite été nécessaires
dans les secteurs de châtillon en bazois
et saint saulge pour le maire de cette
ville aucun habitants de sa commune est
concernée mais l'information a créé un
choc
moi j'étais vraiment secoué de pouvoir
d'apprendre que de ce genre de personnes
puissent habiter à proximité de nos
enfants l'effroyable le parquet de
nevers a qualifié cette affaire d' hors
norme au vu de son ampleur plus de
soixante dix infractions ont été retenus
au terme de l'enquète une instruction
judiciaire a maintenant été ouverte
auprès du parquet de bourges pour des
motifs de viol et agression sexuelle
notamment par ascendance mais également
corruption de mineurs et violences
aggravées
les cinq hommes ont été écroués vendredi
soir les trois femmes laissées libres
sous contrôle judiciaire